[Musica]
[Applauso]
guardare senza vedere realmente questa è
una fantastica capacità che hanno solo
gli esseri umani
nel
1770 oliver goldsmith scrisse questa
frase guasto e il mondo preda di mali
che si susseguono dove la ricchezza si
accumula e gli uomini vanno in rovina è
stata scritta
250 anni fa eppure ancora attuale direi
terribilmente attuale tanto che un
grande intellettuale liberal americano
tony youth è un po di anni fa
io tumori proprio poco prima che uscisse
questo libro questo libro molto bello e
molto duro con noi lo so come come
titolo di questo libro un testo che
dovrebbe credo diventare obbligatorio
per tutti quelli che si vogliono
occupare della mancanza delle
solidarietà e del crescente
egoismo pecore caratterista caratterizza
la nostra la nostra società
da nato punto di vista papà francesco
nella sua hinckley enciclica fratelli
tutti un'enciclica che abbiamo forse
dimenticato troppo in fretta perché
forse dava un po troppo fastidio visti
temi e dice
di aprirsi
aprirsi all'altro
sapere aprirsi al mondo è un concetto
evangelico ma che nell'era della
globalizzazione è diventato è stato
monopolizzato completamente
dall'economia e dalla finanza ci siamo
aperti ai mercati ci siamo aperti al
libero scambio ma abbiamo di menca
dimenticato la parte empatica la parte
umana
di questo di questo appello evangelico
in questi in questi
mesi in questi ultimi due mesi di
terribili per l'europa giustamente il
nostro continente vecchio continente si
è
si è impegnato si è
mobilitato contro questa guerra contro
gli orrori che tutte le guerre portano
con sé contro i crimini che vengono a
che vengono combattuti abbiamo
spalancato gli occhi in modo
letterale fisico ma anche in modo
metaforico pensiamo alla copertura delle
televisioni dei giornali di internet e
anche degli small media e su questo
conflitto dinanzi agli orrori e abbiamo
anche spalancato le nostre braccia
abbiamo spalancato le nostre case per
accogliere un flusso crescente di
profughi
questo è qualcosa che fa onore a noi
europei a noi occidentali ma è anche
qualcosa che contrasta con il nostro con
il nostro recente passato
perché da molti anni forse troppi anni
noi abbiamo girato lo sguardo abbiamo
finto di non vedere abbiamo guardato
troppo distrattamente su una litania di
guerre guerre civili guerre per procura
che colpivano anche il territorio vicino
i nasi in africa in medio oriente
quante volte non abbiamo voluto vedere
una guerra
quante volte ci siamo informati solo
distrattamente sui conflitti
preoccupati soprattutto che da questi
conflitti non venissero come dire colpi
del terrorismo e questo è comprensibile
ma soprattutto che non arrivasse la
piaga dei profughi per usare
un'espressione orribile l'invasione dei
profughi e quante volte abbiamo solo
mostrato una empatia un po fiacca un po
distratta insomma per farla breve
ci siamo come dire abbiamo la capacità
di segnarci e di preoccuparci e di
mobilitarci per le guerre come dire per
i crimini che colpiscono noi i nostri
amici o che vengono fatti dei nostri
avversari e siamo molto abili nel
derubricare qualcosa di brutto
fastidioso ma in fondo un incidente di
percorso quando siamo noi o sono i
nostri alleati o con o quando i colpi
della guerra colpiscono persone che noi
riteniamo di non che non facciano parte
del nostro noi e se guardiamo
e non vediamo
e questi sono un po principi alla base
dell'essere umano che ha questa capacità
di non soffrire per i problemi che non
lo toccano o che non toccano quella
parte di mondo che noi pensiamo sia sì
alla nostra in queste settimane spesso
mi viene chiesto o
tv giornalisti o presunti esperti di
geopolitica si è si chiedono perché il
resto del mondo non si mobilita dinanzi
all orrore di questa guerra perché i
nasi in africa medio oriente seguono
così distrattamente
è la mia prima reazione è davvero spero
che non suoni cinica e che in fondo
perché dovrebbero farlo
si comportano come ci siamo comportati
noi
quante volte abbiamo
rifiutato di vedere quante volte ci
siamo preoccupati
solo delle conseguenze che noi subivamo
per questi per questi conflitti
ci sono soprattutto penso ai paesi
dell'est europa che si sono mobilitati
per primi de qualcosa che li fa davvero
onore per raccogliere centinaia di
migliaia anzi milioni di ucraini ma si
tratta degli stessi stati che nel nostro
recente passato hanno steso il filo
spinato per lasciare morire al gelo
nell'inferno della b russia i profughi
donne e bambini che fuggivano dalla
nuova catastrofe afghana con il ritorno
dei talebani
i profughi siriani i profili dei venute
dallo yemen
permettetemi di farvi vedere allora
qualche cartina
nel mondo ci sono profughi non migranti
che anche peggio profughi sono 80
milioni cioè molti più del nostro del
nostro paese
alcuni chiedono asilo
molti sono profughi al di fuori
del loro paese altri sono profughi
all'interno delle frontiere del loro
paese ma sempre profughi sono hanno
sempre comunque dovuto abbandonare la
loro casa
in siria
nei dieci anni di guerra civile o di
guerra per procura chiamatela come
volete
ci sono poco meno di 4 milioni di
siriani che sono fuggiti all'esterno
della siria e più di 6 milioni di
siriani che sono si dice tecnicamente
interno al display spurs cioè persone
che si sono rifugiate in altre parti del
loro paese sono 10 milioni di persone
più centinaia di migliaia di morti per
anni la guerra seriana la catastrofe
seriana è stata la peggior catastrofe
concessa da considerata la peggior
catastrofe umanitaria del nuovo secolo
anche peggio e nello yemen paese lontano
e quindi ancora più distratto dove le
proporzioni del disastro sono maggiori e
dove noi siamo stati ancora più
distratti perché fatti da una coalizione
a guida dell'arabia saudita e quindi di
alleati politici militari dell'occidente
ecco su 29 milioni di abitanti il 70 per
cento degli abitanti
soffre una crisi
umanitarie ha bisogno di assistenza
quasi il 100 per cento dei bambini
non a protezione sanitaria
poco meno di questa percentuale ha
problemi di accesso all'acqua all'acqua
potabile e forse ancora la stessa
percentuale quelli che non riceve una
alimentazione adeguata
pensate i numeri spaventosi che sembrano
come dire spremere percentuali ma
coinvolgono decine di milioni di persone
a renderlo ancora più grave questo
conflitto
è stato il fatto che la coalizione
guidata dall arabia saudita io confesso
non essere molto bravo in matematica ma
se uno fa i conti il 40 per cento più o
meno dei bombardamenti ha colpito non
obiettivi non ha colpito obiettivi
militare ha colpito scuole ospedali ha
colpito fabbri che ha colpito fattoria
ha colpito università ha colpito
centrali elettriche
ecco tutto questo va impattare sulla
sulla vita e sulla dignità
dell'esistenza di un intero popolo
dinanzi a queste cose noi siamo restati
molto distratti troppo muti e allora
forse questa la risposta perché non si
indignano ma perché usano le nostre
stesse lenti le nostre stesse lenti con
cui noi guardiamo le guerre lontane e in
tanti dicono è una e l'ucraina è una
guerra che riguarda l'europa sbagliando
primo perché riguarda degli esseri umani
e poi perché gli effetti economici
catastrofici colpiranno soprattutto
questi paesi nel medio oriente e questo
non significa voler dire che
si debba pareggiare una cecità con
un'altra è assolutamente positivo che il
vecchio continente si sia mobilitato
ma è altrettanto
negativo che lo abbia fatto o che lo
faccia in modo così selettivo
guardare vedendo in modo selettivo è un
qualcosa che mina alla base delle idee
che si sono formate negli anni 90 e che
io credo non solo perché l'insegna e non
solo perché le ho cercate di applicare
nelle mie attività di post conflict in
medio oriente in cui io credo
profondamente cioè il concetto di human
security di sicurezza umana negli anni
90 si cerca di spostare l'attenzione
nel concetto di sicurezza da una
sicurezza che fosse solo
centrata sullo stato sulla frontiera una
sicurezza intesa in senso militare ha
una sicurezza umana la human security
una sicurezza in cui il centro al centro
dello sguardo vi era che cosa non le
frontiere le sacre frontiere da
difendere per cui era
bello morire ma vi fossero al 100 gli
esseri umani con i loro bisogni e loro
diritti il diritto al cibo
all'istruzione il diritto alla dignità
al lavoro alla alla libertà politica e
attorno a questo concetto venere un
altro molto importante quello di creare
una pace vera capire che la pace non è
solo
assenza di conflitto e troppo facile
in fondo la guerra fredda è stata
assenza di conflitto proprio perché
avevamo paura di una distruzione totale
la pace e la rimozione delle radici
profonde
delle ragioni profonde del conflitto uno
sforzo molto di più ma per essere
credibili per fare tutto questo occorre
appunto una credibilità nello sguardo e
nelle nostre azioni
insomma io credo che quello che si stia
facendo l'europa oggi è un qualcosa di
estremamente e di doveroso e di nome di
qualcosa che ci fa onore
distinguere fra l'aggressore e
l'aggredito è andare in soccorso
dell'aggredito
ma questo bisogna farlo sempre
indipendentemente del colore dalla pelle
indipendentemente dalla dalla lingua che
parli o dalla religione in cui credi
papà francesco ci invita a dire
ricordatevi che aprirsi al mondo
significa essere fratelli tutti è una
consapevolezza che dobbiamo riacquistare
quella della fratellanza umana
guardare l'altro è capire che in fondo
non è diverso da noi questo è un
qualcosa di importante non solo per
costruire un pianeta più giusto o
perlomeno meno ingiusto accontentiamoci
ma anche soprattutto è una lezione che
ci rende più credibili come occidente ma
soprattutto migliori noi come esseri
umani grazie
[Applauso]